Tim starts off this hour in Phoenix hi
Jim how are you hi big steak McCall sure
man what's up hey got a question for you
listen to show and have listened for
quite some time and the topic just come
up and I've missed it or I've never
heard it but we stand to inherit a
sizable amount of money we're guessing
the estate
probably in the neighbor to run two
million dollars and I'm 54 my wife's 52
and we don't need the money but our
homes are paid for our cars are paid for
or we live the life pretty much by the
book in not borrowed a lot of money and
and raised three boys very successfully
well go over yeah well done when will
this money because me thanks my oldest
is a police officer in recently bought
it for expensive home from selling
another home and he said at the top of
the of the pay grade for his payment on
the house and in my middle son is a
doing a third year residency as a
radiologist it's got about three hundred
thousand dollars worth of med school bet
Brennan my oldest who's got about the
same probably in a mortgage and my
youngest is in the Coast Guard it
doesn't have any debt and but what money
saved up but we're thinking is when this
women have now we're talking within the
next you know five to ten years we don't
know we're just anticipating this is you
know we're realist the inheritance is
you know coming from an in-law that's in
their 80s and we're the sole inheritance
so we know it's it's we got to do
something with it we were thinking of
taking the money and maybe not all of it
but half of it and divided it up between
the three kids and then kind of give
them a head start and jump on life
because I would feel data side of that
we never have it half of us and we
managed to make it and they're following
our footsteps what don't want to spoil
them you're here and ideas on that's too
late to spoil them they're too old to
spoil okay great if they're good all it
would do is make them more of what they
already are if they're losers you're
going to make them wealthy losers if
they're if they're if they're great
people of character then they're going
to follow in their parents footsteps of
being frugal
take the advantage of having medical
school paid off for the advantage of a
$300,000 cash account or the advantage
of a paid-for home and use that to
continue this wonderful legacy that your
family seems to have well done sir
well done thank you well we're thinking
but yeah you know nothing has ever been
handed to me and I just hate that when
you send something to somebody there
backfires well the thing is how do you
keep it from backfiring number one money
money makes people more of what they
already are okay
and so just know that that's coming and
so you would if you have one of the
three that was off the rails I'm not
going to give them money you know that's
not fair it's perfectly fair they're off
the rails they got a hair over they got
a heroin addiction I'm not financing it
that's not a loving act and so you know
that kind of thing but that's not the
case with your three so we don't have to
worry about that but the second thing
I'm going to do if I'm you and I have
done this with mine we sat down with
them when they came into adulthood and
went over the estate plan and we said
you know simultaneously as you see what
is going to be given to you to manage
some day we want you to for the first
time in your life realize how much money
is here and we want you to have a moment
where you feel the weight of the
responsibility to carry this legacy
forward and to manage this money for God
this is not a woohoo I hit the lottery
moment right you can say that out loud
to these men and their wives and look at
them and you're handing somebody
$300,000 check you can say a lot of
things to them sure and the second thing
I do is I put them through Financial
Peace University and say that's a you
know you going through this class and
continuing the the smart common-sense
methods of handling money is a is a
condition of this gift because I want
this gift to be a blessing to you not
because I'm a control freak that's a
great idea you can actually put all of
them in one room and do it at once so
they all are scattered across the
country I know but you know you can
afford a plane ticket at this point
right exactly so I mean maybe Christmas
or something we go on a family vacation
you take everybody and pay for it and
and then you announce that they just
that they're
a million dollars among them when this
happens someday the but but you can put
some strings attached to this from an
emotional and moral standpoint and you
know like one of my buddies paid off all
his kids houses he and he bought the
other ones cash houses because he wanted
his family to never have any debt again
anywhere in the family but the condition
was with them and their spouses agreed
to never borrow money ever again under
any circumstances I'm gonna make you
debt free but you got to stay that way
he said you know and that means that my
grandkids are gonna have money so and my
great grandkids are gonna have money and
my great you know and so we're gonna
pass on the knowledge and the common
sense and the wisdom that causes this
lady to have two million dollars that
causes you to be where you are and so
we're creating legacy with information
and money does that make sense well I
appreciate great idea yeah I would do
that I'm gonna send you a copy of a book
called the legacy journey which is the
only book I have written on wealth all
the other books I wrote we're on money
there's a difference and it's got a lot
of that kind of stuff in there when
you're dealing with this kind of stuff
lastly make sure you check with an
estate planning attorney before you give
a gift to that size because under
current tax law if you give more than
15-thousand without structuring it
properly in a calendar year you're going
to get hit heavily with the gift tax you
can do it though easily by doing it
under the unified estate tax credit
methodology and currently you got plenty
of room on that and the law to do that
with what you're describing to me but
you need to there's some paperwork that
needs to be done to keep you from
getting gift tax and gift taxes 55
percent so you want to be sure you do
this right so seek some good estate
planning tax and legal advice as you're
doing the gift when that does occur and
let's see where the tax law changes
because the this new tax law change the
if you all didn't know it change the
estate tax exemptions from five million
to eleven point two million which that
means a couple can have to up to twenty
two point four million right now in
assets when they die and have
estate tax which is most people buy land
it covers almost everybody and that goes
away in 2026 the protection law only
passed it up to 2026 and it goes away
again and comes back down there's one
theory out there that maybe the estate
tax law is finally going to go away the
death tax we call it forever but so
state tax laws changed dramatically this
year this calendar year and if so if you
haven't if you've got some wealth and
you haven't looked at your well will and
estate plan you desperately desperately
need to do that